en el momento en el que hacemos este
vídeo casi todas las ciudades de eeuu
están viviendo las mayores protestas en
décadas
muchas de ellas han terminado en
violencia y saqueos por el momento ya
han muerto tres activistas y un policía
en mitad de la mayor crisis sanitaria
del siglo ahora los estadounidenses
también están sufriendo las revueltas
más violentas en décadas incluso donald
trump ha amenazado con sacar al ejército
a las calles
pero porque protestando
un nombre propio george floyd un
ciudadano que iba desarmado y que fue
brutalmente asesinado por un policía de
minneapolis ocurrió el 25 de mayo de
y os preguntaréis pero de verdad ha
estallado todo esto por solo un hombre
pues por supuesto que no este asesinato
es la gota que ha colmado el vaso eeuu
tiene un serio problema con la
brutalidad policial y los negros son el
grupo que más la sufre así que la
pregunta es porque cómo es posible que
en la primera potencia del mundo tengan
este tipo de problemas cómo es posible
que un país que en muchos casos se
considera todo un modelo de democracia
haya un problema semejante con el
racismo en este vídeo te lo vamos a
contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta y no vale
mirarlo en la uti pediátrica del área
del mundo exacto lo habéis adivinado
estados unidos- los siguientes en la
lista son tailandia y türkmenistán
[Música]
habéis oído bien eeuu tiene a más gente
en la cárcel que una dictadura tan
salvaje como la de türkmenistán o la de
corea del norte pero no sólo hablamos de
cárceles también hablamos de brutalidad
policial atentos
[Música]
asesinado por un policía es una de las
principales causas de muerte de los
jóvenes negros en américa para que os
hagáis una idea solo en el año 2019
murieron más de mil 98 personas a manos
de la policía y de esas mil 98 256 eran
afroamericanos y diréis entonces hay más
blancos asesinados que negros no existe
ni razón el problema es que los blancos
suponen más del 72 por ciento de la
población de eeuu mientras que los
negros solamente el 12 si tenemos en
cuenta estos datos llegamos a dos
conclusiones una que eeuu tiene un
problema con la policía y dos que la
policía tiene una fijación con la
población afroamericana
y alguno pensará bueno esto será porque
en eeuu son inflexibles contra el crimen
el que la hace la paga gracias a eso
seguro que tienen que tener el país más
seguro del planeta verdad pues nada de
eso en realidad este país tiene un serio
problema de criminalidad y lo digo en
serio la tasa de homicidios por cada 100
mil habitantes en eeuu es más alta que
la de países como kenia o sudan en otras
palabras que toda esa brutalidad
policial y todas esas tasas de
encarcelamiento no están sirviendo para
absolutamente nada dicho de otra forma
que los estadounidenses tienen muchas
razones para protestar
[Música]
se desencadenan las protestas en todo
eeuu por la muerte de georg floyd
minnesota despliegan más tropas de la
guardia nacional mientras otras
autoridades locales imponen toques de
queda por supuesto una cosa es que el
motivo de las protestas sea legítimo y
otra cosa muy distinta es que la
violencia esté justificada por desgracia
hay grupos de radicales que están
haciendo todo lo posible por convertir
las protestas en una especie de magma
c's versión coronavirus pero todo esto
ya lo sabéis y lo habréis visto en
montones de medios de comunicación la
pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es por qué
eeuu todavía sigue siendo tan racista
porque tienen a tantísima gente en la
cárcel y a la vez tantísimo crimen en
las calles como siempre hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
el gran problema americano os voy a
hacer una pregunta dónde creéis que es
más fácil que te peguen un tiro en
medellín-colombia o en baltimore eeuu
[Música]
pensando bien medellín es tristemente
famosa por ser la cuna de pablo escobar
mientras que baltimore es la cuna de
edgar allan poe pues con las
estadísticas en la mano la respuesta
correcta es baltimore y sabéis que es lo
peor que baltimore ni siquiera es la
ciudad más peligrosa de eeuu hay lugares
mucho peores y si vamos a ser honestos
eeuu es cada vez menos violento desde
los años 70 las tasas de homicidios han
bajado de forma consistente año tras año
el problema que incluso habiendo
mejorado siguen estando unos niveles de
locura
[Música]
de hecho esta es una de las primeras
cosas que le llama la atención a
cualquier europeo que visite eeuu por
primera vez para que os hagáis una idea
en españa la tasa de homicidios por cada
100.000 habitantes es de 0,62 en eeuu
hablamos de 496 básicamente tú puedes
pasear por casi cualquier barrio de
madrid sin tener el más mínimo temor a
que te atraquen suerte haciendo lo mismo
en detroit y ya sé lo que pensáis todos
este es el gran estereotipo que tenemos
todos los europeos cuando miramos a eeuu
la culpa de todo la tiene la segunda
enmienda el derecho a llevar armas
eeuu les encantan sus rifles y sus
metralletas más que un español el jamón
ibérico y claro si te compras un
winchester pues te entran ganas de
utilizarlo verdad pues puede que las
armas tengan alguna influencia pero lo
cierto es que eeuu no es el único país
con armas por ejemplo aquí donde yo vivo
en república checa también se pueden
tener armas es más incluso hay tours
para turistas donde les deja al disparar
un ak-47 todo esto es perfectamente
legal y sin embargo república checa- es
uno de los países más seguros del mundo
0,60 homicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes y algo parecido pasa en suiza
o israel en estos dos países no sólo se
pueden tener armas sino que además son
obligatorias y si habéis oído bien tanto
en israel como en suiza tienen servicio
militar obligatorio eso significa que
todos los ciudadanos están obligados a
tener un arma al menos durante un tiempo
de hecho si vais a cualquier centro
comercial en tel aviv podréis ver a una
chica por ejemplo haciendo la compra
mientras lleva un rifle de asalto
colgado de la espalda esto
no es porque sea una fanática de las
armas es porque está obligado a hacerlo
mientras esté en el ejército no puede
separarse de su arma en ningún momento
del día sin embargo israel es tan seguro
como lo pueda ser francia por poner un
ejemplo y si vale por supuesto que en
israel tienen otro tipo de problemas
pero la criminalidad no es uno de ellos
y diréis entonces qué es lo que explica
que eeuu sea tan violento por supuesto
que hay muchísimos factores que explican
esta violencia pero uno de ellos es la
pobreza si amigos de visual político los
iuesei pueden ser la primera potencia
económica del mundo pero también uno de
los países más desiguales en hollywood
tienen las mansiones más lujosas del
mundo pero si conduces 30 minutos hacia
el sur te encuentras con tomtom una
realidad completamente distinta
[Música]
y es justo en estas zonas donde se
concentra casi toda la pobreza y el
crimen y en eeuu la pobreza está
conectada a otra característica muy pero
que muy importante la raza para que os
hagáis una idea la renta media de un
negro en eeuu es hasta un 60% más baja
que la de un blanco pero no sólo eso si
eres afroamericano significa que tienes
muchísimas más probabilidades de sufrir
un atraco que si eres blanco hispano o
asiático aunque seamos honestos lo más
probable es que el señor que teatre que
también sea afroamericano da igual la
estadística que miremos en prácticamente
todos los casos encontramos el mismo
patrón a los asiáticos les va fenomenal
después van los blancos luego los
hispanos y finalmente los negros y
repito da igual la estadística incluida
está los condados con negro supone más
de la mitad de los casos de coronavirus
en eeuu y cerca del 60% de las muertes y
diréis
y esto cómo es posible hace casi 60 años
desde que martin luther king pronunció
su famoso discurso eeuu ha tenido
incluso un presidente negro cómo es
posible que este país siga siendo tan
racista pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
un país dentro de otro país como europeo
lo primero que me llama la atención de
eeuu y su obsesión con la raza quiero
decir y rellenado montones de
formularios en mi vida el carnet de
identidad y tarjeta de la seguridad
social etcétera pues bien nunca me han
preguntado por mi grupo étnico es más a
día de hoy pues sigo sin saber muy bien
a qué grupo pertenezco porque por un
lado soy más blanco que el lavado con
lejía así que supongo que podría ser
caucásico pero es que por el otro lado
soy más español que el pecho de bertín
osborne con lo que supongo que también
podría pasar por hispano sin embargo en
eeuu el grupo étnico está presente en
casi cualquier formulario en algunos
estados e incluso figura en tu carnet de
identidad me diréis por qué es tan
importante la raza en este país en parte
la respuesta viene por su propia
historia sin duda alguna una de las
páginas más lamentables de la historia
de eeuu es su pasado de esclavitud
[Música]
durante décadas los estados del sur
tenían esclavos africanos trabajando en
las plantaciones de tabaco y algodón en
el año 1861 abraham lincoln introdujo
una enmienda en la constitución para
abolir la esclavitud y esta fue una hoja
no la única pero una de las principales
razones por las que estalló la guerra
civil una guerra que duró cuatro años y
que consiguió que toda esa población
negra recupere su libertad hasta aquí
todo suena fantástico verdad pues sí
pero a la vez no para empezar a acabar
con la esclavitud no significa acabar
con el racismo tras el fin de la guerra
civil surgió un grupo terrorista el ku
klux klan cuyo objetivo era perseguir y
matar a todos los esclavos liberados
pero no sólo hablamos de un grupo
terrorista los estados del sur aprobaron
varias leyes que permitían la
segregación de los negros es decir que
sí
sobre el papel podían ser libres pero no
podían mezclarse con los blancos
[Música]
ahora imagina por un momento que sois
uno de estos libertos acabáis de ser
liberados y ahora tenéis que buscar
trabajo nuestros vecinos blancos han ido
al colegio tienen buena educación y han
recibido una herencia de sus padres
tienen empresas casas en propiedad y
ahorros vosotros sin embargo empezáis
desde cero y en un ambiente total y
absolutamente hostil que haríais en esta
situación pues muy probablemente lo
mismo que hicieron más de seis millones
de afroamericanos emigrar al norte de
eeuu a este fenómeno lo llaman la gran
migración y no sé si os habéis dado
cuenta pero he dicho 6 millones de
personas que bien podríamos llamar
refugiados para que os hagáis una idea
durante la crisis de los refugiados en
europa llegaron alrededor de 290 mil
personas de oriente medio en el año 2015
en este caso hablamos de 6 millones por
supuesto que esta migración no se
produjo solamente un año sino que en
realidad hablamos de un proceso que
empezó en 1910 y se prolongó por cinco
décadas pero aún así hablamos de una de
las mayor
migraciones de la historia y como os
podéis imaginar los estados del norte no
tenían tantos puestos de trabajo que
ofrecer
de repente llegaban miles de personas
cada año muchas de ellas podían entrar
en las industrias del automóvil de
detroit pero muchos otros terminaron
viviendo en barrios marginales en
condiciones de pobreza y eso explica que
todavía hoy podamos ver noticias como
esta la mayoría de los condados negros
tienen el triple de tasa de mortalidad
por kobe olvidados del cob y por un
momento y quedaos con este concepto
condados negros todavía hoy en eeuu
siguen existiendo barrios o incluso
condados enteros donde se concentra
prácticamente toda la población
afroamericana como os podéis imaginar
esas zonas no son precisamente clase
media y si algo demuestran casi todos
los estudios cuando la pobreza se
concentra en guetos muy específicos es
cuestión de tiempo que las tasas de
criminalidad empiecen a crecer y os
preguntaréis entonces qué ha hecho eeuu
para resolver este problema pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
y orden ley y orden ese fue el eslogan
con el que richard nixon ganó las
elecciones de 1968 ajustes logan se
cristaliza una política muy clara la
única forma de acabar con el crimen es
ser inflexible
[Música]
y aquí tenemos que hacer un pequeño
paréntesis veréis tanto eeuu como reino
unido tienen un sistema legal totalmente
distinto al que tenemos en europa tus
leyes están basadas en la llamada common
law para que os hagáis una idea en un
país como españa tenemos una cosa
llamada código penal
ahí están escritos todos los supuestos
delitos y su correspondiente pena los
jueces sólo se limitan a aplicar ese
código penal en cada uno de los casos en
eeuu sin embargo casi todas las
decisiones judiciales se toman en base a
casos previos y por eso habéis visto
tantas películas de juicios donde el
abogado llega y dice en el caso del
estado de minnesota contra jim johnson
hicieron esto y lo otro y lo demás allá
pues bien uno de esos casos que dicta
doctrina ocurrió en el año 1982 en el
llamado caso
harlow versus fitzerald en ese juicio es
donde se aprobó una nueva doctrina legal
atentos
[Aplausos]
cualificada es una doctrina legal en la
ley federal de eeuu que protege a los
oficiales del gobierno de ser
denunciados por acciones discrecionales
realizadas dentro del ejercicio de sus
funciones y amigos de visual política
este es el principio que explica
tantísima violencia policial por ejemplo
el policía que mató a georges floyd ya
había sido acusado de brutalidad
policial en otros casos pero al no haber
pruebas flagrantes y ser este hombre un
oficial en ejercicio de sus funciones
ningún tribunal pudo hacer nada contra
él y este es el principio que protege a
miles de policías desde los años 80
[Música]
pero no sólo eso imaginad que sois un
policía en detroit vuestro trabajo es
evitar los crímenes pero obviamente no
podéis ir a un barrio marginal y parar a
todo el mundo
primero porque necesitaríamos una orden
judicial es decir que necesitáis filtrar
a la gente que es más propensa en
principio de cometer un delito pero como
os podéis imaginar los criminales no van
por ahí con un letrero en la frente que
diga criminal y aquí es donde el racismo
juega un papel fundamental porque las
estadísticas no mienten los
afroamericanos son la raza con más
riesgo de exclusión social y eso implica
que son más propensos a ser víctimas y
más propensos de ser agresores
[Música]
por supuesto que esta no es la única
variable pero si es la más fácil de
detectar a simple vista y por razones
obvias y todo esto explica otra realidad
tan triste como cierto
la policía de los ángeles acusada de
hacer selección racial pero no sólo eso
una cosa muy especial del sistema legal
de eeuu son los fiscales generales y los
sheriff en muchos casos son elegidos
mediante elecciones es decir que al
igual que uno puede votar al alcalde al
presidente oa su senador también puede
votar al fiscal general del estado o
incluso al sheriff del condado y eso
explica que es el ix como éste se hayan
hecho tan famosos en todo eeuu
[Música]
un tipo que cree en la igualdad de
oportunidades en el cumplimiento de la
ley y encierra todos sheriff joe arpaio
esto explica que en las últimas décadas
eeuu ha endurecido sus leyes muchísimo
más que cualquier otro país por ejemplo
en españa si te pillan con una cantidad
pequeña de marihuana algo que solo es
para consumo propio puede que ni
siquiera se considere un delito sin
embargo como la policía de kansas te
pille con un poco de marihuana aunque
solo sea para consumo personal no lo
puedas vender porque sea muy poca te
pueden caer hasta seis meses de cárcel y
si da igual que en california la
marihuana sea legal en el estado de
kansas no lo es y eso significa que como
te pillen con marihuana te cae la del
pulpo con estos ejemplos ya os podéis
imaginar porque en estos momentos hay
más de 22 millones de estadounidenses en
la cárcel habéis oído bien 22 millones
para que os hagáis una idea el problema
de las cárceles en estados unidos es tan
bestial que está empezando a generar
incluso un agujero en las cuentas
públicas cada año se gastan hasta 80.000
millones de dólares sólo en mantener sus
prisiones todo esto explica que una de
las pocas cosas donde demócratas y
republicanos están de acuerdo sea
precisamente esto
[Música]
la iniciativa primer paso refleja un
nuevo consenso en justicia criminal pero
realmente reducirá los encarcelamientos
masivos en otras palabras que parece que
está muy claro que eeuu tiene un
problema con el crimen y que las recetas
que han estado probando en los últimos
años no parecen funcionar muy bien por
supuesto todo esto sigue sin justificar
los saqueos y la violencia de algunos
grupos que están radicalizando estas
protestas pero es importante que el
congreso empiece a tomar cartas en el
asunto cuanto antes de hecho mientras
preparábamos este vídeo ya hay un
congresista que ha hecho esta propuesta
hablamos de justin amash que hasta el
año pasado pertenecía al partido
republicano y que ahora se ha afiliado
al partido libertario atentos esta
semana voy a presentar la propuesta para
acabar con la inmunidad cualificada para
restaurar la capacidad de los americanos
de obtener consuelo cuando los policías
violan sus derechos constitucionales así
que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
qué tipo de políticas creéis que pueden
ayudar a integrar
a la población afroamericana como se
puede acabar con el crimen y a la vez
acabar con la brutalidad policial podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
polític y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle al like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]